let's talk about Syria and why it's so
hard to get earthquake relief to people
there
the earthquakes that hit Southern turkey
and Northern Syria have been
catastrophic
in Turkey there's an official state of
emergency in the infected region the
military has been deployed emergency
crews are flying in from all over the
world and there are still so many people
in desperate need
but when it comes to Northern Syria the
situation is even more complicated
because even though it's fallen out of
the news headlines the war there isn't
over and most countries are very
reluctant to deal directly with the
Assad government including the US it
would be quite ironic if not even
counterproductive for us to reach out to
a government that has brutalized its
people over the course of a dozen years
now
[Music]
this is the area in Northwestern Syria
that's the worst affected by the
earthquakes it's mostly in idlib and
Aleppo provinces
and it's an area under a patchwork of
control by different groups so you've
got areas controlled by the government
and on the ground that means the Syrian
Army pro-government militias and groups
linked to Russia and Iran there's a
pocket that's controlled by kurdish-led
forces and then there's this area which
is controlled by different opposition
groups including one known as HTS it
used to be linked to Al-Qaeda and the
U.S and others have labeled it a
terrorist organization now in government
territory some help has arrived
countries include including Russia Iran
Iraq and Algeria have all sent Aid to
the Syrian government but the government
controls what Aid goes where so they
also control what does or doesn't end up
in opposition areas the government has
basically made it clear that they would
allow it to be channeled or transported
to different areas but they were not
allowed to go to basically what they
refer to as terrorist organizations and
the problem is that the regime sees all
opposition groups as terrorist
organizations now there's already a
system in place to get Aid into this
part of Northern Syria and it mainly
goes through just one border crossing
with turkey
it's at Bob alhawa and it's the only
crossing the UN is authorized to use it
goes directly into opposition territory
but for three days after the earthquakes
no aid went through
[Music]
the U.N says damaged roads on the
Turkish side made it impossible to get
trucks to the Border Aid has now started
to go through babalhawa
um
the UN also says it's talking to the
Syrian government to try to open up
other routes that cross government
territory I have no doubt that all the
parties involved will do their utmost to
facilitate the transport of humanitarian
Goods to all syrians who need it there
is a possibility that a few humanitarian
shipments might be able to cross to
opposition-held areas and that happened
in the past but the problem that even if
that happens that the scale of the aid
delivered through region control areas
will not be enough to address the huge
needs in Northwest Syria even before the
earthquakes there was already a
desperate humanitarian crisis there
about 4.6 million people live in
northwest Syria more than 4 million of
them rely on Aid to meet their most
basic needs things like food shelter
Fuel and close to 3 million are people
who have been displaced from their homes
in other parts of the country
and remember we're talking about the
same places the government has been
bombing for years
you have constant airstrikes and
systematic targeting of Civilian
facilities that includes not only
residential buildings but also power
stations water stations hospitals
schools and all of that now something
else people are talking about is whether
International sanctions could prevent
aid from getting in but that's
definitely not the main problem the
sanctions are mainly imposed on
specific
government entities that have been
contributing to the
valuations permitted also you have
sanctions targeting specific individuals
but all the sanctions that are composed
either and by the us or other actors
don't prevent humanitarian AIDS from
being channeled to Syria it really comes
down to this in Syria all assistance has
to be Associated agreed and monitored at
the highest levels in coordination with
the Syrian government and often Russia
and Turkey too and mostly it's done
through the U.N but that takes time
while right now people are freezing
hungry
injured
or even worse still trapped under the
rubble